segula est basée dans les yvelines
attrape c'est une entreprise qui couvre
l'ensemble d'un cycle de vie d'un
véhicule et de ses moyens
d'industrialisation pourrait voir un
petit peu plus clair on va demander les
explications alexandre qu'une bonsoir
vous êtes le chef de responsable projet
compétition et innovation pour
l'entreprise segula ça signifie quoi la
petite description que j'ai fait un
petit peu obscur tout à l'heure alors la
petite description furent en fait c'est
ça aujourd'hui c'est du las est un
groupe d'ingénierie sts et qui est
capable de supporter l'ensemble des
différents domaines que ce soit le
ferroviaire l'automobile
le naval l'armée dans des travaux
d'externalisation
de la part de différents clients au sein
de ce département automobile on a créé
un département compétition innovation
qui est à même de traiter tous les
sujets un peu exotique ce soit des
projets en interne ou des demandes
particulières de petits constructeurs ou
de grands constructeurs ce que vous
travaillez aussi pour des grands comptes
sociaux dans son présent et symptômes et
sa renault par exemple un certain nombre
de véhicules qui sont exposés ici il ya
un petit peu de segula dedans disséminés
concrètement vous y faites quoi par
exemple quelle a été la dernière
collaboration avec avec psa peugeot psa
on ne travaille on travaille
essentiellement sur nous en tant que
compétition innovations on travaille sur
des concepts cars mais on a un certain
nombre de
le collaborateur qui sont détachées chez
psa et qui les supportent en termes
d'ingénierie sur différents projets
comme la 208 et vous développez aussi
des projets en interne c'est le cas ce
que vous présentez aujourd'hui salon
présente aujourd'hui le plongera le
projet agora projet qui rassemble
l'ensemble des technologies de se
développer en interne chez secula et
qu'on a souhaité mettre un peu en images
et en musique sur sur notre stand cette
année alors agora c'est quoi c'est un
concept car un véhicule à l'élaboration
concept à boras un concept c'est
l'ensemble des sujets innovants qui ont
été développées chez nous on a rassemblé
dans un
petites voitures c'est un crossover
sportif urbain ça s'est hissée un bon
nouveau
qui rassemble
l'innovation principale qui est la
chaîne de traction vous voyez derrière
vous qui est le premier des brides de
temps destinés à l'automobile
combien de personnes vont travailler sur
ce projet comme une personne qui
travaille alors dans l'entité
compétition innovations on est petite
quinzaine et pour l'ensemble de ce
projet là on a mobilisé une centaine de
personnes sachant donc l'entreprise est
basée sur trappe
c'est le coeur de vos activités ap c'est
le
le siège du centre au dessus du
département automobile mais pour ce
projet là on a fait travailler
l'ensemble de nos antennes partout en
france
qui avaient des savoir faire spécifique
dont on avait besoin sur le projet à
gore l'avenir d'agora c'est quoi
justement là où vous le présentez sens à
l'automne
l'avenir d'agora donc représentent
différents concepts a une vocation
commerciale
on fait pas ça juste pour se faire
plaisir donc il ya un but et
l'idée c'est que ans
suite au salon avec nos partenaires qui
sont bombardier et it frag
puisse envisager la construction d'un
prototype roulant et démontrer que les
solutions qu'on développe chez cdu
l'assuré solution réaliste et qu'on peut
mettre dans la rue à court terme il ya
plus de 250 270 marques sont présentes
ici sur le salon bleu gris mobile
comment vous tirer votre épingle du jeu
comment on fait venir justement les
ailes et les clients
c'est désolant vous recherchez des
visiteurs pour la reconnaître vos
activités pour faire connaître nos
activités il ya deux ans on a présenté
la première monoplace 100% électrique
les performances de
en huit mois cette année on propose
autre chose au constructeur propose un
savant faire notre capacité d'innover et
à proposer des choses différentes de ce
que leur département r&d peuvent
galibert travailler en général
donc c'est pas vraiment pour le grand
public en fait les raisons de votre
présence ici c'est pas leurs taux pour
les constructeurs c'est pour les
constructeurs c'est pour les
équipementiers
c'est pour les partenaires il y en a
on peut être à la fois client et
fournisseur c'est ça qui est intéressant
dans le cadre de projets internes
on a des fournisseurs ou des partenaires
et ça c'est intéressant d'avoir la
double casquette au travail est déjà sur
d'autres projets ça se passe au moment
du salon de l'automobile ont métaux
entre parenthèses et mobile reste
maintenant aux grosses têtes déjà vous
n'avez pas mono projet on a on travaille
toujours sur la monoplace on est en
train de construire le premier
championnat du monde de monoplace
électrique
on travaille pour des constructeurs
le sort du constructeur français ou
étrangers et puis bien évidemment la
partie r&d interne qui développe des
projets comme agora toutes ces
précisions un nouveau continent ce tour
du salon de l'automobile on parle de
l'électrique ont fait un point sur ce
tout électrique cette folie du tout
électrique quasiment tous les
constructeurs s'y sont mis pour ce
mondial de l'auto 2012 de paris encore
une fois les 270 marques présentes
rivalisent d'ingéniosité dans le domaine
de l'électrique et de l'hybride
tour d'horizon des constructeurs
installés dans les yvelines on a une
offre la peugeot là lyon voiture tout
électrique une voiture tout électrique
encore aujourd'hui inévitablement
présente de réelles contraintes
d'autonomie donc une voiture électrique
et on pense nous pour encore quelques
années quand même sera forcément
concentré à une un visage quasi
strictement urbain
on croit beaucoup plus dans la
technologie de l'hybride diesel on va
pouvoir proposer des voitures comme une
3008 hybrid4 est bien qui fait 200
chevaux qui propose 4 motrices et qui
est homologuée à environ 4 litres 5 de
diesel aux 100
la marque française porte aussi un
intérêt tout particulier aux pays en
voie de développement
elle présente cette année une berline
301 réservée au marché asiatique russe
et africains direction le stand de bmw
le constructeur allemand présente cette
année sa nouvelle marque écologique
explications avec le responsable france
vous avez sous les yeux les bmw i8
concept et i3 concept qui sont à 80% à
peu près identique à ce que seront les
modèles de série dans un an
ces voitures
sont faites pour l'électromobilité avec
des matériaux ultra légers comme la
fibre de carbone ou l'aluminium est en
plus totalement responsable de
l'environnement puisque on utilise
beaucoup de matériaux recyclés
sur ces dommages les premiers véhicules
seront commercialisés fin 2013
chez ford c'est une grande première le
constructeur américain s'apprête à
commercialiser deux véhicules
électriques et hybrides en france ces
modèles étaient pour l'instant
uniquement disponible aux états unis où
le marché de l'électrique et de
l'hybride représente 5% du secteur
automobile on présente une focus 100%
électrique donc là vous n'avez pas de
moteur thermique
vous avez 150 km d'autonomie c'est
parfait pour un usage urbain ou
périurbain ou pour les usages
professionnels et à côté on présente une
mondeo hybride qui elle va être parfaite
pour voyager parce que vous aurez une
hybridation sur l'association d'un
moteur électrique à d'un moteur
thermique qui vous permet en ville de
baisser considérablement les émissions
et les consommations
mais malgré tout d'avoir beaucoup
d'autonomie pour un voyage et on voulait
voyager loin et en famille qu'on pense
que les moteurs thermiques ont encore
des progrès à faire et notamment chez
nous avons développé un moteur
bicylindre s'appelle le twinair nous
travaillons également sur des carburants
alternatifs faut savoir que fiat est
leader en europe sera le gnv le méthane
donc des camions encore plus propre que
le gpl et nous avons aussi une large
gamme de véhicules gpl
la 500 électrique sera mise sur le
marché américain l'année prochaine
l'europe devra encore attendre
on termine avec lumineo une pme des
yvelines spécialisée dans le véhicule
électrique
l'électrique c'est l'énergie du futur
pour la ville pas pour les grandes
distances c'est évident un problème de
capacité de batterie mais pour la ville
c'est vraiment l'énergie du futur parce
que pas de pollution pas de bruit
facilité de mode de pompe à essence
aussi dans la ville vont y penser c'est
quand même pas si facile que ça les
progrès techniques auront lieu d'abord
sur le poids du véhicule qui qui
baissent tout le temps et aussi sur
l'autonomie grâce à de meilleures
batteries mais là le saut
technologique sera fait plutôt dans
trois quatre ans ou voir un peu plus
sans oublier la twizy de chez renault le
véhicules électriques en auto-partage
pour l'instant exclusivement sur le
territoire saint quentinois